people of the internet retrorecons who
are here today we have part one of a new
let's play series featuring harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone for pc
now i actually streamed this live over
on twitch but it has been edited down
here and condensed for youtube
so feel free to watch all this in great
detail maybe a little bit here a little
bit there throw it on in the background
whatever you want to do let me know what
you think of this format and as always
guys thank you so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon hello harry
oh we got the portraits we got the suits
of armor
here comes albus welcome to hogwarts
school of witchcraft the heck was it
look at his eyes
now hogwarts is full of seats he's
wearing 3d glasses
behind every door but keep in mind
not all secrets are rewarding okay
whoa the mouse like
it's not traditional mouse controls the
way you would expect
i have to keep my it's like tank
controls so like w
or i'm sorry a makes him do this so yeah
this game is so old you guys like it was
honestly it was one of those first games
that
i want to say did it come out before the
movie
follow me harry because i had no idea
there were actually
multiple versions of harry potter and
the source for stone the video game
they made this one for the pc hello this
was the first one we can show you how to
get around
they made one as a first shooter for the
playstation
which was sort of based on this one but
some of the things were in different
orders against the dark arts class
i should probably be paying attention to
this though
yeah so they made that one for the
playstation the one for pc then they
made another one
which was a dif again a different
version this was much later
and don't stop you'll climb up collect
all the beans you can find
and meet us in the next room hello fred
and george right so we got kind of like
a little
you just run into it he'll jump
the controls are so weird man
all right we gotta collect all the beans
they have like a hidden passage here or
something
oh oh we can't do any spells yet we
haven't learned anything
another bean
is that peeves peas
they left you out of the movie not out
of the game
all right how did you guys get over here
no apparently let's try jumping
you can't do that then press the jump
button to jump across
if you've gone down you can climb back
up and start over
all right meet us in the next room we'll
take the shortcut
and meet you there ah shortcuts that's
right
the castle does have a lot of shortcuts
but yeah then they made another oh
there's that ghost again
what okay that's actually pretty a
pretty nice touch
the fact that they have the ghost just
moving through the walls like that
but yeah then they made another version
of the game that
came out on gamecube i want to say ps2
and xbox
peeves out of the way dude he's always
causing trouble
peace doesn't like first years so watch
your step
oh we ain't worried about peeves dude
we're not worried about peeps
come on man okay is there anything down
there that i exactly but what could we
do
see the movie's missed out on peeves uh
comic relief
potter and you better watch out for me
oh we're watching out for you is there
anything i need to collect down there or
should i just go ahead
dude peace with with the insults already
whoa
all peeps we're good we're good we're
good
appreciate this friend george by the way
the hang of this
in hogwarts you'll find all sorts of
wicked treats
to pick up a treat just run over to it
chocolate frogs boost your energy okay i
actually bought every flavor
i'd forgotten about that that the
chocolate probably worked
we need 25 beans harry come back when
you've got them all
come see us and we'll show you the way
to class
i remember i remember the bean
collecting
oh fred and george their currency was
birdie bought beans all right
i got all these beans terry we couldn't
have done it without you we need the
beans for some
experiments here's a wizard card for you
you've earned it
yeah dumbledore class is your secret
good luck well well well
if it isn't the famous harry potter the
famous harry
potter malfoy and you do well to show me
respect look at his head these are my
fellow slytherins
his body's so small this is just the
angles are going to win the house club
and the quidditch cup you better stay
out of our way potter
let's go boys let's go boys
what is up okay they had to have the
movies had been out move along
does he i mean he looks just like what's
good
oh what is his name
he looks just like him
what is that dude's name don't tell me
don't tell me yet chat
i will think of it oh he's in he's in
game of thrones too
david bradley boom
i was like i know this guy's name all
right
all right so it looks like we're having
class with slytherin oh there's there's
some ravenclaws too
today we'll learn how to protect
ourselves against
the dark magic with the flippendo spell
[Music]
dodge my one flipping man hold down the
mouse
button i do remember this part release
the
button release the button when you're
done all right where do i start okay
start up here
i was never really good at staying in
the lines guys
how's that pass mark 50 percent oh we
got that
we got that 98
all right an outstanding effort mr
potter that's right we get an o on our
owls
for the spell wait what again you can do
why do we have to do it again i already
got 98
man i passed
with flying colors
[Music]
oh it upped it see 65 percent now
how was that with 96 i thought that one
was better honestly with the most
points at the end of the year wins the
house
cup i was worried there for a second
the house with the most points at the
end of the year
wins the house yeah you said that
15 points for gryffindor
you mentioned that again what again
[Music]
boom told you dude
oh give us an o on our owl
20 points for gryffindor
griffin that's right i wonder how long
this game is in total it can't be that
long
collect the challenge stars
in all of harry potter video games all
right get ready you're gonna hear this
about
500 more times this game
[Music]
there we go
all right i think it's okay yeah it's
back as far as it needs to go
anything over there ooh a gold star
[Music]
oh should i go okay i don't think
there's anything i can do in there
okay so now we're in that room that we
looked through over there
oh and then this just takes us to that
spot we were trying to jump up to
oh but there's a switch there well
done now you go on
sir nicholas hello harry potter
i am nearly headless nick the gryffindor
house ghost
this is a saved game book it's not bad
really when you touch it
your game will automatically be saved
and on we go all right quarrel how about
that man
perfect score on the flapindo challenge
nintendo spell on this
block to knock it out of the way all
right
let's start the block away
[Music]
okay i think that's as far as it'll go
possibly
see i'm i'm so trained to look for
secrets like i'm looking everywhere
anything over there
that's one thing i think would be
hogwarts legacy really needs
to succeed there needs to be a lot of
secrets that
you find just by kind of exploring
hogwarts on your own
rather than just being told here's where
you need to go i mean this game's pretty
old right so
the linear nature is somewhat expected
[Music]
him on his backside can be quite a
nuisance
oh there's too many of them give me my
beans give me my birdie pop beans
[Music]
yeah boy you better give me those beans
back man
i gotta pay fred and george is that all
we need to do
get home harry ron talked about their
exciting first days at hogwarts
there was much talk about the break in a
green god's wizard back
since harry and his friends were
expecting that they're flying less oh my
goodness
is it time for uh the flying lesson yes
sir is that actually the moon
adjust your flight speed and i thought
nearly headless nick sounded a little
bit like john cleese earlier but it's
just like
i might whistle that off
oh my goodness
whoa i don't know what i'm doing i
didn't i didn't listen to your guys
i have no idea how to speed up
man if if only it would let me use
something else
oh look at that look at that you're the
youngest seeker in
a century
to mcgonagall oh we are on a time limit
you guys
[Music]
no slow down harry
whoa these wings should
challenge you oh my goodness
82 and we've only got 35.
am i not doing nearly as good as i feel
like i am
i mean i don't think i've missed any
have i
down down down down
okay
[Music]
we gotta win the house cup for
gryffindor you guys that's why this is
so important
this is hurting my pinky finger so bad
oh i missed that one i think i missed
that one i'm almost positive
let's try it what is this
[Music]
okay i think that's giving me slightly
more time
each time i go through
dude my pinky is in crying out in pain
right now
like i'm not using the mouse at all for
this you guys this is all my
left hand on the keyboard
mr potter 14 points for gryffindor
oh come on you may practice flying at
any time you will find the option on the
oh okay that's cool
you're only for the lesson harry but
i'll teach you a new spell i've learned
on my own oh yeah let's go hermione i
i think i know i think i know magically
lock things
but target mischief will be very pleased
with that attempt harry
hey k11 welcome and thank you for that
follow as well i saw that pop in
right before i hit the go live button
so thank you so much for that follow
welcome to the story here at retro
recontour
how long do i think hogwarts legacy will
be i think it'll be a pretty lengthy
game i mean they're they're calling it
open world
[Music]
dude i did not think i got the 95
percent marvellous
why is hermione giving out
would award you at housewife 20 house
points here take 20 house points i know
flitwick would give you these i know
flitwick would give you this many points
now you try using alamoura we still have
a few minutes before the charms lesson
that door in front of you is magically
locked as soon as hermione stops talking
we'll chat more about okay there we go
yeah i think uh
i think it'll be at least like a 30-hour
game but probably a lot more
especially if you want to see and do
everything maybe like 20 hours for the
story
15 20 hours somewhere in there and then
a lot longer when you do all the side
missions and stuff
all right here we go have you seen the
non-edited of those
wait how do i change spells i wonder
does it just kind of auto detect
you've got it now can you find the two
secrets in this room
[Music]
another reason i wanted to go back and
play these though is i think it'll be
really
interesting to kind of
do some youtube videos on what hogwarts
legacy could learn
from the old games because let's be
honest as far as like reviews go
the old games really didn't review all
that well
[Music]
and they're not i don't think they're
considered to be great games some of
them are even considered to be pretty
bad
uh goblet of fire i've actually never
played goblet of fire i've heard it is
the worst one
we're gonna find out together on stream
all right she said discover the secrets
i mean is it just the one
secret
i don't think i can climb that so let's
go over here
let us go over here who is that
that ravenclaw the art so different
folio magi
tilly toke awarded order of
merlin first class for saving lives
during the
ilf ilfor chrome incident of
1932 when a dragon swooped down on a
bunch
full a bunch on a
beach full of sunbathers dude we're
racking up the spells quickly correct
when
oh wow i'm actually way worse on this
one
it's at least 50 though just got to get
50 for the person
oh i botched it oh
oh can't win them all guys can't win
them all
oh look at him shake his head that was
awfully close
don't lie to me flipwick it was not
close three out of four man
hardcore it's like no reduce you sorry
you enter the wingardium leviosa
challenge
to practice the spell you don't get your
points you're gonna lose to slytherin
is this like all in his first day too we
haven't even went to
the gryffindor dormitory yet he's just
been like class after class after class
guardium leviosa on that statue then
move it onto that large plate
all right so now we're going to win
guardium leviosa on these little
cubes here
oh he said it that time oh can i not
move
okay good we can drop it back up
rc dude what's up welcome
all right there's one played this game
with my brother on playstation 2.
we were talking rc in the beginning this
like i had no idea there were so many
different
versions and i'm not talking about just
like you know nowadays there are a lot
of different versions of the game ps4
ps5
xbox series x pc like there are a lot of
different versions
but there were like three different
companies who worked on
a harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
game this as far as i know was the first
one
then they made one for the original
playstation which was kind of loosely
based on some of the stuff this one did
but there were differences
then they made a
ps2 gamecube
and xbox one and i'm gonna try to play
all three of
them as far as the fantastic beasts
movies go it
it'll be it's it's gonna be much earlier
even than that
all we know so far is that it takes
wow there's our first death
there's our first death as mr palta okay
now
how much do i have to do again that's
the question i can't believe the music
just went out
so strange
and this is where we messed up and died
wow i really don't want to die again so
i'm going to focus on this focus on
hitting this jump this time chat
that was that was my first death in this
in this whole game
jump okay there we go potter you know
what i'm gonna try to do this very
quickly this may be a mistake
turn around in time and jump back
that's right harry that's right dude
okay let's go let's go let's go
oh my gosh he scared me dude see why
didn't he why didn't he grab
i i was expecting him to grab that
little moving platform but he didn't
that time he grabbed so
congratulations that's the bridegroom
thank you you've collected all the
challenge stars
20 uh coley could there possibly be a
triwizard tournament
highly unlikely again given the time
frame because
the old triwizard tournaments they they
had to ban the tournament because so
many people died
they were that brutal now what i will
say
is like in the wiki it does
mention that there were a couple of
attempts at
bringing back the the tournament
the triwizard tournament
a couple of attempts at bringing it back
and so we don't really know like as far
as like the canon goes we don't really
know
what that means exactly we know of
course in harry potter's
day they brought it back in goblet of
fire and yet again
somebody died whoa hedwig
what is this harry don't be late for the
hopology lesson
i'm waiting at the entrance to the
greenhouse see you there soon
thank you hermione i really appreciate
that reminder
not to be late for my homology lesson
but yeah so if if they do have the
triwizard tournament it would have
to be as like a uh they could pull it
off but they would have to pull it off
in a way that's like hey
we're trying to bring the triwizard
tournament back
[Music]
and it may be like a slight variation of
it
oh there he goes okay he was just
checking out the wand
okay okay we didn't imagine that chad
speaking of peeps speaking of
peeves what is this a boss battle
oh oh no dude he is like taking away our
health quickly
no
[Music]
out with you
yeah they need they need peeves in
hogwarts legacy man
i don't even know where i'm at right now
hey potter do you like surprises
malfoy's got a present for you
hey watch your step around here
slytherins don't like gryffindors
potter potter
you better watch your step around here
yeah he's definitely gonna be late he's
been sidetracked by peeves
now he's sidetracked by crab and goyle
herbology should be outside am i right
oh malfoy is stopping us now though well
well potter
we meet again having a tour of the
castle are we
this is as far as you'll be going you
won't get past this another boss fight
how hard you try oh boo hoo
because i can't get out of the castle
boo hoo cracker should make you feel
better
where's it crackers good fun here catch
oh we are gonna fight malfoy
famous or not you won't get past me
wait what i can't cast a spell
i can't i can't cast spells guys
how do i throw it okay you run over to
it
[Music]
oh take that malfoy wizard cracker
to the face watch it another
oh that was about to pop don't belong
with
i love how they just introduced this new
mechanic don't even tell you what to do
oh come on pick it up get rid of it get
rid of it harry
what malfoy
ouch oh no we need to grab we need to
grab the chocolate frog
it actually did tell me what to do
didn't it with the space bar not
leaving this castle until i finished
don't even try for that one
oh he moved again the little punk
get away harry oh we're almost dead guys
we cannot let malfoy get the better of
us
we can't let malfoy have this one on us
guys
come on throw one just one yes there we
go
take that malfoy to the face
the actor next time would have been
brilliant drop dead fred the young one
oh for uh rick the oddball
it's a spell it sounds like he is saying
nintendo
flipping nintendo
what are you throwing wizard crackers
they they actually
are a thing ruby s
keeper of keys and crowds at all hello
harry it's me
hagrid good to see you these are the
hogwarts castle grounds and i'm the game
keeper of course
of course i don't believe how quickly
everything grows around here
your friend hermione's at the entrance
to the greenhouse waiting for you
yeah and hagrid you're just sidetracking
me further
you're sidetracking me further i got
stopped by peeves
i got stopped by crab and goyle i got
stopped by malfoy
now even hagrid's out here like hey dude
come on down to my house for some tea
after your lesson potter is this my
lesson is this the greenhouse
no i don't think so it's easy out here
welcome to greenhouse three second years
what do we have here
fire it's not a blast ended screw so
fire salamanders
come on chocolate frog yeah
all right we haven't been full health in
a while
okay what happens if i blast this guys
okay it just like stuns them for a bit
another chocolate frog
okay oh should i try to jump over him
now what if just run by him he's already
back up and moving though
come on sneak by okay that should open
the gate right
yeah there we go okay
why is professor sprout have her
classroom
[Music]
to get to the herbology greenhouse
it's just like riddled with these
[Music]
monsters
you guys i'm so bad with directions
even in games okay here we go yeah yeah
all right
it's like where in finally
oh and hermione here comes hermione and
neville they just like
made it no problem
oh my goodness
you want some more beans don't you yeah
here we go here we go all about the
beans
all right thanks for helping us out
harry here's a wizard card then
hope you don't have this one yet ooh
come on late eighteen hundreds
we're checking on all the wizard oh
that's gryffindor we're checking on all
the wizard cards to see when they're
born
so if they could potentially be alive
for hogwarts legacy
we made it professor sprout we made it
yes
i am professor wow that looks nothing
like that
send you spell which is useful against
all manner of dangerous plans
all the other ones so far look just like
the movie
hold down the mouse button and follow
the pattern
then release the button
oh yikes sorry we just need 50
on the first try 50 we good
we're good yeah it's gonna be tough guys
it's gonna be tough
points for griffin to get that 20 points
for gryffindor continue with the lesson
mr potter
come on come on come on
boom give me that 20 points for
gryffindor
outstanding incentive for a first year
20 points for gryffindor oh yeah we're
winning the house cup dude
we don't even need dumbledore's extra
help we don't even need dumbledore's
extra help we're going to win that house
cup
trust me this is a typical species of
venomous tentacular was right incendio
to wilt it
insanely work now connect the challenge
stars to complete your lesson
all right before we collect that
challenge star though
yeah i thought so i was like they gotta
have something back here
the animation's so weird
more beans more beans why am i not
surprised
i walked right into that one incendio
[Music]
come on dude surprise me give me
something besides beans in one of these
you know what technically i guess i
don't need to destroy all of them
[Music]
and those spikes don't hurt us too much
that's good nicely done
all right we gotta just i mean we gotta
go ahead and complete it now we gotta do
all of them
enough with the spikes
come on wizard card where's your card
i'll tell you chad i tell ya i'm already
tired of these beans
i'm already tired of the birdie bop
beans make sure we grab that star
oh this dude's coming after me gotta
fulfill him
[Music]
too much magic at once for harry all
right there we go
got rid of all the vines
so now we can do this
and this
the harry potter game that i i feel like
i remember the best
is chamber of secrets
another frog nice dude
this room's kind of creepy
why can't i not hit him from here
what harry harry castle spell right
turn around make the jump over there
another spot for
for flipping
and another chocolate frog
oh yes i didn't know if he was going to
make that jump or not
come on wizard card where's your card
not beans
disappointed every time i see beans chat
all right and now we are back
anything over here secrets
yes what's the secret
oh my goodness dude if i run all the way
over here and it's just a bunch of beans
if i run all the way over here for a
bunch of beans yes
okay good wizard card
worth it worth it
wait is that slytherin i think that
might be slytherin
let us check the folio magi
oh no that's not slytherin edgar
stragler 1703-1798
just missed the time period for
hogwarts legacy inventor of the sneaker
scope
dude i had forgotten all about the
sneaker scopes
so hopefully we'll see more challenging
spells in in a game
or more challenging puzzles i'm sorry in
hogwarts legacy
all right did we get all the stars
sprout congratulations mr potter
you completed the challenge but did we
get them all you've collected all the
challenge stars
20 points for gryffindor that's that's
what we have that's what we want we want
all the challenge stars
i haven't hit a save point recently hold
on i'm going to run until i hit a save
point
there you are i hope you did well this
game's so old i have no idea if it has
got something
or not be best to discuss it back at my
heart meantime
you're going to be late for your
broomstick training off you go dude what
a packed first day
like i mean they're just constantly
rushing go here go here go here go here
go here go here go here you got to be
late go here go here you got to be late
the voice lines i know dude hagrid oh
yeah
oh yeah you gotta love hagrid okay wait
is this the way to the first flying
lesson
i have no idea our second flying here
comes neville he looks quite upset
let's go and see devil what's wrong dude
please help me
oh did they take you remember all right
here we go dude this is it and you want
me
to give you his precious remember i
think i'll need this is it
fly rockets here up a tree what's up
rockets here indeed man you can catch me
it's been like four months or something
crazy dude
like four months four months of a little
break
knocked malfoy off his broom give me
back neville's remember all malfoy
i didn't think this was in earlier see
if you can catch it
and you better watch out for my blood oh
dude
yes malfoy you can't control it with
your
uh with the mouse it's so annoying
dude malfoy we are absolutely
wrecking you right now bro
[Music]
malfoy absolutely dominated
you damaged my broomstick potato here
take this stupid thing
i know you oh wow yeah malfoy i'd be mad
too
if i just got owned like that in front
of everybody
except there were no kids but hey you
know in the movie all the kids were
there
you've got my remember all back neville
i got your back do you i'll be able to
find my toad now
i never understood the pork the point of
the remember
i never i mean it's like it tells me i
forgot i'm forgetting something i
remember now
i left trevor near the herbology class
there should be one sir that he
toads there should be like a second step
to the rim brawl like you hold it
oh
i'll admit you have remarkable talent on
a broomstick
first year students may not compete in
got that right mcgonagall in your case
we might overlook that rule harry
gryffindor's first quidditch time is
later this afternoon
see you then oh my gosh
you guys it's like they never heard of
like simulating time
passing they're trying to fit every
single thing
in this first day i mean it feels like
the first day i just need a save point
please
all right i'm just gonna assume and hope
that it auto saved for me because i
really need to hop off
all right we're about to find out man
okay let's do start game oh yes it's
right there
sweet okay even though this game is so
old they still have the technology of
making sure that there is a indeed
a save point